hey what's up guys my name is a Turner
welcome to episode 9 of game programming
okay so yesterday we made this awesome
screen class and what else do we do um
and we also initialize it and got it
running and today we're going to
actually use this class to fill some
pixels in on the screen and um and
basically demonstrate our all of our
future plans to render stuff onto our
screen so again our game is still in its
normal staff sometimes it takes forever
to open here it is with just a black
screen so we're going to use um we're
going to use a screen class to actually
control what gets entered onto the
screen so let's get started with that so
again in screen dot Java in our screen
class I'm just going to create a new
method called render so public void
render now I will give it a parameters
in the future like offsets and stuff
like region scrolling but not right now
because I'm one we don't need it yet so
I put it in and this is going to contain
two for loops okay so I'm just going to
type for int y equals zero Y is less
than height Y plus plus and then inside
of this for loop right not not outside
it but inside it I'm gonna make another
one for X so for in x equals zero X is
less than with X plus plus and I'll
explain all this right now so what a
full loop is is it's kind of the same as
our while loop right a while loop
basically keeps doing whatever's in here
in chronological order until this
statement is not true
so until running equals files in this
case so for loop does the same thing
except it keeps on right it keeps on
looping through what's in in between the
UM in between the the curly brackets
until
this statement is is true so in other
words what's happening is is is we're
creating a variable called Y by setting
it equal to zero you can set that
variable as an integer um and we're
saying that keep looping until Y is less
than Y let while Y is less than height
keep looping keep doing what's in the
brackets and every time you can play one
successful loop add one to Y so what's
happening is every time it's completing
everything that's in between the
brackets it's adding one just one to Y
and it's going to keep doing it until Y
is actually greater than height because
that's when it's going to stop
so while Y is less than height um keep
uhm keep doing what's in the brackets
and it's going to do the same thing for
X but for X is less than width now how
is this going to practically translate
into into our arm into our screen what's
going to happen is height remember is
we've defined by creating the screen
class height is equal to this and width
is equal to that so in other words our
height is the height of our our our
buffered image and the width is the
width of our buffered image so what's
going to happen is each one of these um
each one of these loops is going to
basically render one pixel to the screen
one pixel of a particular color which
will decide in the future but um or
we'll get the computed computer to
decide for us in the future
so yeah each one of these like
iterations represents one one pixel now
why is this X loop inside the while loop
well the reason it's inside it is
because we actually wanted to render
every pixel on the screen not just all
of the Y pixels and then all of the X
pixels because what happens is again
I'll look and paint out now just to
demonstrate this to you guys
sorry paints on a different hard drive I
got an SSD from like all my main
programs and primary stuff and then I've
got my go like two other hard drives my
Tutera by one or one terabyte one apart
from the 128 gig SSD to hold all my all
my things and they're both like pretty
much full so yeah anyway um so I'll just
I'll just draw a grid that older may be
a bit small alright so again each one of
these represents a pixel and and what
I'm basically saying here is that if we
if if this was outside right if these
four loops were like this then what
would happen is it would um it do every
one of these pixels
well I just
every one of these pixels and
these pixels hopefully you guys and say
that adequately right but then it's got
all these pixels that it wouldn't do
because remember it's going to keep
filling in these pixels to acts while X
is less than width which is for the
entire width and it's going to keep in
keep filling you'll keep filling in all
the Y pixels with with color until um
wise y is greater than height so while Y
is less than height is going to continue
doing that which is for all this but
what happens to all of these pixels we
need all these filled in as well
and by putting and by putting this
method up this loop inside this loop
right now creating a nested for loop
we're basically saying that for every
pixel for y we're going to go all the
way through the width of the X pixels so
in other words what we're saying is when
y equals zero for example fill in all
the X pixels when Y is equal to one fill
in all the X pixels when Y is to fill in
all the X pixels and so on and what
happens is for every Y value we're
feeling the Dean type the entire width
of the screen the entire width of X
values and what we end up in in the end
is an entire screen filled with with
data okay so hopefully that'll help you
guys out in explaining that now on now
that we've created this loop we can
actually start applying pixels and this
might be a bit difficult to understand
so I'm going to try and um explain this
as much as I can so pixels again we're
referring to this array of pixels pixels
X plus y times width equals and then
we'll set it to a color so just to
demonstrate this I'm going to set it to
pink or magenta so again zero X to
indicate that we're gonna use a
hexadecimal FF 0 0 FF I don't think it
went over the hexadecimal forget not to
them in a second okay so what are we
saying here this line of code we're
saying that that obviously pixels is an
array which contains every pixel on our
screen write an integer representing
everything's on our screen this is this
is the index of which one we currently
want to access so again I shouldn't
probably should've closed paint.net um
but
as you can imagine each of these pixels
is an integer and we need to basically
tell it okay this time around and in the
loop we're going to be adding data to
um
through this pistol too
right here or I don't know we're up to
like the 200th iteration in this loop
we're going to be accessing this pixel
here so in other words we need to tell
this pixel array which which particular
index which particular pixel we want to
apply this data to so the way we do that
is we tell it to access you know this
now what does X plus y times with now
again just like a few months ago I
showed you that what happens with our
our loops is we're accessing the entire
width of the entire width of the screen
and so what we need to do then is
actually say that okay if X is if X is
like three because what's happening is
because this is a one dimensional array
um there is no like coordinate system so
we kind of have to make our own and the
way we can do that is by doing this so
we're saying that if X is 20 right say
we just want something like 20 I'll just
write over here we want to access the
coordinate 20 X and like I don't know 30
Y all right we want to access that
coordinate now if we count pixels let's
just say that that's 20 X and that's 30
Y so we want to actually access ah you
know this
and I access this pixel right here for
example right and that that pixels going
to have this coordinate now what happens
is if obviously there's there's no room
here to actually put coordinates and we
sort of need to convert this into
coordinates and the way we can do that
is by using this math so what we're
saying here is it because because the
way that pixels work is like every
number this is just one single number
it's not two numbers it's something
that's not a coordinate it's just one
number so what happens is when it gets
to the edge of the screen right let's
just say that's pixel number 50 this
this one right here is going to be pixel
number 51 52 53 54 etc okay hopefully
you guys get that go soften pixel zero
up here it's going to go all the way to
the end of the screen and then it's
going to go down one row and that'll be
pixel number 51 so it's it's sort of
scanning and it's scanning it from left
to right so what we need to do here is
say okay so 20 again more maths so 20
because we've selected you know for
example on the 22 bit coordinate 20 plus
30 times width which let's just say this
width is
hundred okay so what's going to happen
is going to say okay so the X is going
to be twenty and then the width is going
to be um or the Y rather the wipe the y
coordinate is going to be Y times width
because think of it this way this is
actually kind of hard to explain
um I don't know if you guys getting this
drop a comment letting me know if you um
if you understand what I'm saying
but basically what I'm saying here is
that um I don't know it's just a maths
it's just a basic massing you know that
there are 100 pixels per row all right
there are 100 pixels per row so
naturally you know to go down a row
right you have to select which role you
want so in this case and remember that's
actually how it's happening because
multiplication and division comes before
addition and subtraction um so we want
to go down a row 30 and a cross to
column 20 okay that actually might be
better if I talked about it in columns
and rows rather than X and y-axis and
coordinates and stuff like that so again
we're going all the way down or row 30
which might be here right we're down to
row 30 and we're also going across 20 20
pixels okay
so short that's pretty much all you need
to know this is just a way so with this
times width thing you can actually
replace and I'll show you guys that in a
second actually but right now we're
filling the entire screen with pink
okay now hexadecimal was it last episode
maybe two episodes are going on yeah it
would've been too upset ago I talked
about hexadecimal formats and how that
works so this is pink again if I open
paid on map and I bring this guy here
you can see that if I answer
F F 0 is 0 0 F F that will give us pink
right here so that's the hexadecimal for
pink or for magenta we we can't just
enter just like that into Java if we
want to if we're actually using a
hexadecimal we have we actually have to
put 0 and X as a prefix in front of that
hexadecimal as you can see the error
goes when it's fine now if we wanted to
refer to binary for example we'd put 0 B
and then you know the binary okay and
you'll see that actually doesn't work
because we need to be using java version
7 1.7 um I should probably actually
upgrade to 1.7 but we'll keep this
project in 1.6 but um that's how you use
binary we're using hexadecimal so we
indicate it by that and again it does
not matter if this is uppercase or
lowercase F's you can make some of them
up case you make something log has up to
you but that is a color um now good
we've got a render method and what when
were rendering stuff the screen so now
let's actually render something on to
the screen because I've talked for a
long time and I could I could end the
episode here as well we are at 13
minutes but um I think you guys are
enjoying the longer episode so I might
quickly just render something onto the
screen so again we've got this screen
method now right here in our random
method we need to actually render the
screen now it the way we do that at
first of all we actually need to call
this render method it's public so we can
do that simply by typing screen which is
the class dot render and that will
actually just execute this method and
remember because we are in this random
method which is in this a while loop um
this screen door random method will get
get run again and again so it will
constantly update our screen now the
second thing we need to do is actually
set this pixel array right which
contains all of our pixel data to 2
pixel array which at it which is
actually what tells our buffered image
what to display and we can do that by
again creating a full loop which
basically just copies the array so for
in I equals 0 I is less than pixels
length I plus plus so again this is
going to be a full loop it's going to
run for the duration of of pixels so how
lot how many how many um values we have
in pixels the size of that array it's
going to kind it's going to do that so
it's going to go through every index in
the pixels array will set pixels I
so again pixels at index I will set that
equal will set these pixels equal to
screen dot pixels so equals spring
pixels I so yeah obviously it's going to
go it's going to work its way through
every every bit of variables I what's
what's the proper name for that are
actually nor I'm sitting here trying to
think up of a good net of a good name
but every um I guess every index every
um every every part of that array every
not every variable every integer in that
array is going to go through every
integer all right and I is of course
going to cycle through all of our I'm
not gonna teach you basic full lips you
should already know that if not I'm sure
you could google it or something but
it's going to go through every every
value of this every arm every variable
is contained in the pixels all right and
it's going to set it equal to the script
to to this so essentially we're setting
this
equal to this okay and now we actually
have to draw that pixels around to the
screen now we've created a buffered
image but we're not drawing it on till
on to the screen or we're drawing right
now if this is this black color so under
here remember this is in chronological
order make sure you don't do it here
because if you if you do actually draw
your pixels here what's going to happen
is it's going to draw the pixels and
then on top of the pixels it's going to
draw this this black rectangle so make
sure it does follow in chronological
order so make sure you do it after so G
dot draw image which allows us to
actually draw our buffered image to the
screen three the G to draw our image and
I don't know what parameters I'd specify
so the image first of all which is just
image the starting X&Y and the size of
the image which is going to be ah get
width again and get high and then the
image observable just put an OL okay
symbols that
so we're basically drawing this image to
screen so let's hit the debug button see
what happens
okay so right now we have a pink image
and let's actually get rid of this this
black is filling in so now what we've
got is is this draw image and it's
drawing this image with this color
and then here it is you can see it's
pink which is our color so brilliant
that worked now the thing that I wanted
to show you is the coordinate system so
again if we want to target pixel 20 and
and y 30 so X is X is 20 Y is 30 I hit
this Run button and I'll zoom in so you
can see you can see the one pixel here
oh it's actually more than one pixel
because we're scaling up by three but
that one pixel there is is affected and
if I actually play around with this a
bit
just come over here I can change this to
40 hit ctrl s and it will actually
change the location here now you see
that the previous one was left behind
because it wasn't raised and we'll talk
about that in the next video so I hope
you enjoyed please hit the like button
if you did and I'll see you guys
tomorrow bye
you